This is the carol N.E.H. American English dialect recordings
collection tape number nine side
B..
Of its county about this
activity while later relayed
by old he took a picture but
only I guess a little empathy after with the parents
died and that makes
you right of and help her with that they
had to bring up
model loosely of really
in bed
we did a lot had a lot of
remodel Did he ever sleep. Well
no no no didn't bother with the
grief of repartee Linda.
That's fine I think that now that your father was a good
name and getting them. They only gave rise to the
building of
the race of
the people we all describe a
lot of do you have a pretty
good size. Do you know
of
the healing
of of we hope to have
created a sense of I
had been he had a lot of happy and healthy happening
particularly early. Played with the heart
of a
child of the Church
of
Jesus and then
different kinds of support
by the people.
In
heaven.
Now
as for
the
next in
last
I see so you had the start of surviving the
corners.
Or with the
world.
Right
here front
to help.
Really together
right.
Hard as you would have done it myself
and I.
He probably has programs or did you have a mind.
And
the record
sounds teachers Jenny Harrison.
Yes. I think part of
your do you happen to have
any
one
know.
What the.
Last part of the. Party.
In charge of
drawing in the
back.
Does have a
life
because I was
like oh it's
probably when it was started I said people can.
Probably
just where
is she. Growing up
and going to
school aged kids
just dissipating a lot of.
Uses for program. Did you like to
see thing like my father. I know.
Yes I've
always liked.
When you get
together. What are
some of the happy
times together and how you celebrate.
We always say from
my place.
They probably knew a lot of thing a lot of definitely that was the
most followed him all the time whether
ever
you have no I don't because I think for my they must resign from the
heart anywhere
and my father would.
But. They say.
My
question when I heard all this beautiful music to say could
produce like to play the
clarinet and he loved to sing.
And
my father enjoyed that was
just we just
need somebody
to say what don't we wish we had a tape
recording that part of the tape was always
ready for
his
tape and
then
later
we just abandon the door
and everything
is
just
one
of your mother in the family
had for the family celebration has the
special recipe special this is a serial number that was particularly
delayed
for the sake
of
breaking.
Now that sounds and.
Everybody go where.
Good
morning. Go.
That sounds fun
and
full.
That was a quick.
Repeat
to
relay the
tape.
For that one.
I did you ever learn how to make that famous.
Nobody would make.
They also make this case to go
after
all. This is just a
problem
I had was
it.
About two or more.
After that.
You said you came here about forty years ago. May
have thirty seven what actually brushes
again a person.
That
was pretty rough for
everybody and he evidently were fortunately hiding a job
early and that
was
about four years I
was great.
But I hear tell you're not afraid of it and I said you're not afraid of working news
yourself. And then.
The
reader
then the do
gooders
like you said you had your one of
the senior workers
are
retiring.
Yes. Even though you could get a job in
the Depression
or tail end of the Depression years it wasn't always easy.
He kept coming back.
I
wonder how they were taking care of people
here time. That couldn't get
jobs provided the few didn't need enough to keep the job right
away
or
I
left
but
you
think
about the way things are going
now that happening now
and I wonder
you have many black families.
I saw some of their
my
work.
I
didn't
but
under
the conditions
my conditions would be
considerably better than nine hundred seventy seven and
ninety
thirty people
finding places to live.
People finally
got
you by your
place. Or you
have
no idea for you for
service.
That's
not
my favorite because I think it's
great for you
for your
one.
Did any of them ever come
out
a
of.
Well that's what many people are like. But
I hope we
have a quality.
Well
that's what I
think we hastily Bremen.
But I either come at the same again and she would like
to tell me about your families or your
sister or your mother. Did
you as a child were you talked to or do any of those sort of thing.
But. Here.
And I imagine this started when you were quite young.
You think of
my grandmother was a
family to say learn to bake
bread when they had to stand up on a little
chair in order to see where they were too
short and they were taking them about. And
more than a funny.
Well
it's wonderful to be talking to
restart. I'm sure
they helped you with your family the Rodino now the
same life many of
our young people that get married
today probably never been in a
kitchen. A place.
Can
Ride for.
Last year was your garden right on
your property.
And we're with this you're
relating to a
Campbell
Quest QUEST there
now. That's how they are saying
the.